yeah i mean
i like to think of myself as an honest
guy like there's one rule
i i'm almost
too truthful like my girlfriend's
sitting off camera and she would agree
that i'm
i'm almost almost to say the truth too
much because that's that's just the
rules i live by so
i would much rather just know the body
count and make a decision from there i
have certain standards that separate yes
it's none of your business no but you
know it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
though yeah it does matter business it
is most certainly business it is what
the hell is it
yes it is it is because
it shows to me
like a sense of self value um
i think especially from a female like
from a male perspective like when you
meet a meet a girl
it shows to me a sense of self value
because
i think everyone could agree here that
most guys
can sleep with someone and it could mean
nothing whereas with girls not every
time okay there's exceptions to the rule
but i think a lot of times it takes a
lot to get into that into that place
and
what are you getting from it like
so why are you shaking your head i know
girls like sleep with guys just because
they want to have sex
yeah yeah same
a guy can do it let me do it they're at
that point where i'm a hoe i've done it
yeah
men and women are different and
understanding and so men have to have
women have a certain level of
requirements to sleep with the man
because some people say oh women have
sex and because it takes a lot more for
women to have sex but i've literally
seen girls that will sleep with men and
feel no tapping yeah but they don't they
don't start like that they do they don't
they don't not typically they they're
not typically they don't want to go
they don't typically start they they
become that but when they're 15 16 17 18
whenever they lose their virginity
they're not they don't they're not born
a savage they're made
because they've just been and that's and
that's why men don't want girls that are
ran through because you you can't
connect as much the more people you
slept with but i grew up seeing girls
sleeping around i've seen it yeah so i
saw it i grew up in that community
that's why i can speak on it and growing
up i saw a lot of girls and it was kind
of like
you had hope you had girls who were
known for giving head you had this girl
known for this like in different areas
there's a bunch of hoes like a lot a lot
a lot a lot so every time things have
changed like things have society has
actually changed
but why isn't it why is it in a man's
business to know your past because your
past dictates your future if you have if
you have it does if you have habits your
habits are who you are so if you spent
if you spent five years sleeping around
let's just say
then
how is he to know that you won't do that
again when you turn 32
like like because you have that past
like i'll give you an example i used to
drink okay in college i drank and i
decided to stop drinking i don't drink
anymore and the thing is there's always
a part of me that's going to want to
drink because i did it i started i used
to really like it and so it's like if
you used to be a hoe there's a part of
you that's going to want to go back no
matter how much you suppress it okay
because you used to do it again as well
i got yeah i think your habits like if a
guy is sleeping with everybody is it
going to be hard for him to stop yes but
the thing is men and women are different
we value different things girls don't
care as much if they get cheated on as
women do they don't i'm sorry it's not
the same because then we wouldn't pick
the guys that cheat like i'm sorry we go
for the guys we go 100 of women want 20
of men so if we're picking the guys that
are gonna cheat there's there's one out
of three men that are virgins so go pick
them if you want to be the guy that's
faithful you are what you do
but the thing is though to be honest
i've never heard
well from friends and stuff and our
culture in uk is different
people don't really have a culture
that a guy would even leave you based on
how many people you've slept with do
they really care no no
no
and one thing i noticed you see with
this whole body can't thing yeah girls
lie they literally chop their body parts
inside so you may ask a
where's your body how they may lie
what's your bank account statement then
the thing is though there's never again
an honest answer i know girls that have
lied there wasn't that um
there was that answer i i go to the
extremes right
i'll take a polygraph test you take a
polygraph test let's go that's how
committed i am like that is the place i
was okay and what happens when the body
count is behind did you wait did she do
it do you take a polygraph test
i'll take one you can ask me anything
anything okay i am fully committed what
happens when you hear something you do
not like what happens and you're already
in love with this girl like you you know
you want to marry her like for me would
that be the determining thing no and you
know that it was her part no no
when you're in that first
um
interaction yeah it depends on the
damage right it does depend on the
damage like if it's so much worse then
it's so much worse
but
i
believe in truth like and it may be an
optimistic idealistic view of the world
but
i think you should be willing to put all
your cards on the table and i think the
truth comes out eventually maybe not
today maybe not today maybe not tomorrow
but like if you've been sleeping around
town he's gonna he's gonna run into
someone you slept with exactly so so
like you're right women i i do see hoes
get wiped all the time i i do see it and
a lot of times the men don't know but
the truth comes out or they leave
because they're too damaged are there
some who have been true so okay let me
just say this now there's no win-win
then for her it's either you tell the
truth
you
like the guy will leave you and then you
try going the straight and narrow you've
been literally celebrating let's say
five years and that's not your lifestyle
it could also be it could be the worst
it could be to lower your standards and
think hmm you know i'm not a virgin so
maybe i could date outside of the church
and he doesn't have to be equally yoked
because how yoked am i if i'm not if i'm
not a virgin anymore that's right a lot
of women do anyway
they do work
outside of the church
and they're going out with
should i say ghetto guys they're going
out of guys who are proper hardcore you
know what i mean don't believe in no
church they believe in saturday night
i'm going out raving that's what they
believe in so so they'll be in the
church and dating the guy yeah the but
he's not a husband right
it's just the way you told the story
that's
what i mean no no no he wouldn't be
husband material okay but then again
they might want him to be husband
material
he might be really good in bed
and you know good in bed might qualify
him to be
you know he he might be able to do
to make me happy i've i've just found
that a lot of the women in the church
have too high of standards because they
they aren't what men value anymore
and so i just i've just found a lot of
like 27 28 29 to 35 year olds that
aren't virgins requiring a man that's
equally yoked and i think that's a tough
ask and i think if we want to build
families like that's going to be tough
that's going to be hard so people can't
change them people can change they just
have to lower their standards that's
that's all as long as they lower their
standards i think that's fine i think it
also women and women can do that very
well lowering the standard
i think
i think if that was true then 50 of
women that hit 30 wouldn't be single and
childless because one again one out of
three men are virgins the men are there
that want to commit
so women women um on dating apps they
only swipe right five percent of the
time so that that's telling me
that we don't in fact lower our
standards i think on the body count
thing and to your point right i think
you have to be realistic you have to
know where you're at and i think
if you come in with a realistic view and
an open conversation
you at least increases the chance of
speaking truth right i'm not saying
business
that to me as many of you know i was
just banned on tick-tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible